[Music]
today we are checking out the brand new
insta 360 rs one inch edition this is
the newest camera in their lineup of
modular rs cameras but this looks a lot
more like their other ones that you may
have seen me review in the past the
insta360 one insta 361x that's a try out
the insta360 one x2 this is really cool
and i already got a chance to check this
out i am not doing an unboxing because i
was actually on a trip to italy and i
didn't have a chance to film the opening
of it but what's important is it's here
and it has made its way around the world
and back again to tell the story now
what makes this so special is it has a
one inch sensor that has been
co-engineered with leica you can shoot
up to 6k 360 videos at 30 frames a
second which allows you to do a thing
called video reframing so you basically
are filming everything in 360. you don't
have to worry about getting the shot
because you can later on either use the
desktop app or the app on your phone to
reframe it and basically reshoot what
you already shot it's incredible because
this does have the one-inch sensor that
means it's going to be really great for
low light performance with photos and
videos it also has flow state
stabilization plus a 360 degree horizon
lock it is ipx3 water resistant which
does not mean that you can submerge it
in water but it will be safe for light
rain or water splashes
i'm not a very good swimmer but i'm
trying my best
so
don't put it under water it's not
waterproof if you're familiar with
insta360 at all then you're very well
aware of the invisible selfie stick it's
so awesome now when you're out filming
you
definitely look a little silly and
people may make fun of you but that's
okay because little do they know that
this camera that you're holding on a
very long stick will actually get you
some incredible footage when you get
back home and edit that stick will
magically disappear in post and it
really is kind of magic if you've never
experienced it the first time you see
the shots that you can get with these
cameras it's so mind-blowing the in-app
experience is actually really great when
you get used to it it can be a little
confusing at first when you open it up
there is a little tutorial that you can
go through but the more that you use it
the more comfortable that you get and
the more incredible things that you can
do with the shots that you get and the
best part about it is you can do this
all mobile it's on the go and you can
instantly export those and share them i
know we're getting to to you
so you can sync this camera directly to
your phone using bluetooth or wi-fi and
instantly get all of the content off of
it they also have some really fun
inspirations in this thing called shot
lab so this will let you shoot a set of
clips and it will automatically edit
those together using ai it's really fun
because you just shoot some shots and it
does all the hard work for you this is a
shot that i filmed while walking around
pompeii and it's cool because all you
have to do is walk at the same sort of
speed for about 50 seconds holding the
camera out to your side for several
different shots and it edits it together
just like this
they have a few accessories there is a
new quick reader which i actually don't
have but allows you to plug it directly
into your phone and you can transfer all
of the footage directly from the sd card
to your device and you won't have to use
wi-fi or bluetooth or kill the battery
on your camera now this is the invisible
mic cold shoe that you can use with the
rode wireless go or the go to and this
is just like the invisible selfie stick
but we now have an invisible microphone
adapter this has a little cover on it
too to protect the lenses
so here is the actual camera and like i
said it's modular so you just pop off
this top little piece this is the
one-inch camera sensor and that will
just directly connect right here into
the base of the handheld camera
oh whoa
okay
surprise so everything just comes apart
thus it being modular and this is where
you have your usbc and your sd card and
if you want to plug that right back in
you just slide it in just like so
and you can reassemble
and go out and shoot
[Music]
this is probably one of the most
important pieces is this little lens
cover i always make sure i have this
with me because you do want to protect
these lenses because they are 360 so if
there are some smudges or scratches that
could affect your shots so protect the
lenses at all cost get your power button
our record here's a little lcd this will
give you access to
different menu options you could do time
lapse time shift loop recording burst
star lapse interval hdr photos regular
photos and of course just video i pretty
much just use this a lot for video but
it is cool that you can do all these
other things with it so when i was in
italy i just kind of went around i
didn't really make it a thing i just
kind of had the camera i was filming so
now that i'm back i get a chance to go
through and look at all of the footage
that i shot which is the most exciting
thing so taking a look at the app is
really cool because you have access to
all of your content and it's very easy
to edit
so let's find a little clip here so i
can show you guys what it's like
this is kind of what you you'll see you
see kind of this 360 view and you can
change it from nine by 16 16 by nine
one to one and even this ultra wide
screen which is really cool but i love
that i can just zoom around
and reframe whatever i want so you click
this little plus button this brings you
a few other options you can
automatically go to tiny planet ultra
wide wide linear narrow and this will
give you different types of views so
each one will look a little bit
different look at me swimming i'm just
kicking my little leggies but this is
probably one of my favorite
things is
they have
this viewfinder so basically i can go
and reframe this entire shot by just
moving my camera around so i'm going to
push record and right now i'm basically
filming so it's like i'm there but i'm
not i can zoom in
i can do a little reframe see some boats
can go over here see the boat that i was
on do a little zoom out do a little zoom
super zoom in
see where our boat captain is don't know
he's not there let's see what i'm doing
i'm right here down swimming look at
this face i'm distressed because i am
not a good swimmer but i can go over
here look at the view i can zoom in see
that boat zoom back out it's like i'm a
cinematographer of my own shot
like i was here and now i'm reshooting
it again i'm like i'm spinning all the
way around
there's the boat where'd i go where am i
there i am
swimming swimming
swimming
okay export gonna do flat so you can
export to 360 as well but since i just
did all those little shots to it i'm
gonna click export and now
it's exporting and i have
a video that i just filmed myself it's
so cool they call it reframing which
kind of makes sense because you're
basically going back in time to what you
shot already and reframing the shot so
now i want to go outside and test out
some of the shot lab features these are
so much fun i can just shoot a bunch of
things and then it automatically in the
app edit them together
the first thing that i'm going to test
out since we're out here is the flash
i've tested this out on my rs review but
it's so much fun and it's so easy to do
you basically just extend your selfie
stick hold
the camera to your back walk and then
when you import it into the app that's
where you can make the edits and make
yourself go really really fast wherever
you want
so cool which i can do in real life but
we can't
carry on
[Music]
that's it let's find another location
this one that we're doing is called flip
my day and i've wanted to try this for a
really long time but i haven't had
anybody around to help so jake let's go
flip our day
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was the first look at the new
insta 360 rs 1 inch edition i am having
so much fun with this camera i can't
wait to take it on more adventures if
you guys would like to get more
information about this camera or
purchase it i will put a link in the
description a huge thank you to insta360
for partnering with me on this video i'm
such a huge fan of their cameras and
have been for so long so i always love
testing out the latest and greatest see
you guys in the next one bye
[Music]
you